[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: It's primarily
a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
PAUL SAXMAN: Hello, everybody.
Welcome to this week's Google
Maps Developers Live, formerly
Google Maps Office Hours.
With me this week, we have a
couple of members from the
google.org Crisis
Response Team--
Pete Giencke and Ka-Ping Yee.
Do you guys want to introduce
yourselves and say what you
work on here at Google,
or with google.org?
KA-PING YEE: Sure.
My name is Ping.
I'm a software engineer at
Google Crisis Response.
And I'm the tech lead of the
Person Finder Project and the
Crisis Map Project, which you're
going to see a little
bit about today.
PETE GIENCKE: And I'm Pete
Giencke, as Paul mentioned, a
GIS data engineer, and I support
the Crisis Map Project
and several other geo
efforts to get data
into Map and Earth.
PAUL SAXMAN: Awesome.
So, with that, why don't we
just dive into the demo.
So you guys got some pretty
interesting stuff to show us
today, things like Crisis
Maps, the People Finder,
Person Finder, and
let's see it.
PETE GIENCKE: Sure.
We'll see how much time we have,
but we'll do as many
demos as we can.
OK, So as I mentioned, I'm
Pete and this is Ping.
So we want to spend about 15
minutes today just providing a
high-level overview of Crisis
Map and offering some
technical detail
along the way.
So before getting started, it's
worth mentioning that a
majority of what's been
developed and what we'll be
demoing today is based on the
same tools on APIs that are
available to external
developers.
So a big goal of this project
is to open source as much of
the code as we can.
And the number of--
maximizing the amount of
external tools we're using and
minimizing the internal tools
just means that it's going to
be a lot easier when it's time
to push that code out.
So why don't I talk real quickly
about the Crisis
Response Team.
So the Crisis Response Team was
formed in January of 2011
after the Haiti earthquake,
just as a way to better
organize the Google and
community resources in
response to an event, really
making critical information
more accessible in times
of disaster.
Crisis Map, that we're talking
about today, is the
application that our team uses
to mash up crisis-related
data, such as evacuation routes,
flood zones, and
disaster-related imagery.
The goal for us is to take
crisis-related geo data that
traditionally has required
special software and expertise
to be able to view.
It takes data that also lives
scattered across the web in
many different formats and just
makes them available to
all users without any kind of
special software, so really
just making critical disaster
geo data more available.
So when we combine these layers
on a map, different
organizations that don't
normally communicate with one
another are able to see their
map data in context with the
different layers.
So we're going to go over to a
quick demo here that Ping is
going to display.
Since we launched for Hurricane
Irene in 2011, we've
responded to many different
disasters, most recently
Hurricane Isaac.
So what we're seeing here is
our Hurricane Isaac map.
Isaac hit New Orleans as a
Category 1 storm on the
seventh anniversary, just about
the seventh anniversary
of Hurricane Katrina.
And it caused an estimated $2
billion worth of damage.
With hurricanes, we have a
little bit of a lead time.
So in this case, we were able
to work with the states of
Florida and Mississippi, the
Red Cross, NOAA, and other
organizations with really
relevant crisis-related data
and prepared this Hurricane
Isaac crisis map, preparedness
map, really.
So what Ping is demoing here,
we have shelters.
We have many different
layers, so he'll
pop a placemark there.
This is coming from
the Red Cross.
It's a Fusion Table layer.
It provides nationwide active
and open shelters
and number of beds.
We also have things like
evacuation routes
that are on the map.
So we have--
from FEMA, it's a
Fusion Table.
It's all of the evacuation
routes for the coastal states
likely to be impacted
by a tropical storm.
We also have, coming from
the Google Maps
API, current traffic.
So this is what I mean by
providing crisis-related data
in context.
And if you turn on the
evacuation routes PDF here,
too, so this is providing more
local level data from the
Mississippi DOT.
So really, if you're a user,
your city, your town, your
apartment has been evacuated and
you're looking to get out
of the city in advance of Isaac,
we want to provide that
information in context so
that you can provide--
so you have enough information
to make an
informed decision here.
Maybe you see that one
evacuation route has a lot
more traffic than another.
Maybe you take the less traffic
way out of the city.
So this is just really kind of
taking information that lives
separately on the web, combining
an evaluated way so
that people can really make
better decisions.
PAUL SAXMAN: And Pete, is that
kind of why you chose Fusion
Tables as a back-end
system for--
PETE GIENCKE: So, yeah.
As part of our Crisis Map,
we're able to accept many
different formats.
Many of those come directly
from the Maps API, so it's
built-in support, so KML.
Fusion Tables is one of those,
GEOSS, Google Map Tiles.
And then all of the built-in
Maps API layer types that we
find really useful, especially
for crisis response.
And as you see Ping turning on
and off layers, it's worth
mentioning that much of the
application's overall
functionality is built atop
Google Maps API here.
So hiding and showing layers
is just built into
the Google Maps API.
OK, so one of the questions that
we get asked is how do
you find data for the web,
or how do you find
data for the map?
What does good data look like?
Really, what is the life of a
crisis layer on the map here?
So we thought that we would do
a quick demo just to show how
we find-- how the Crisis
Response Team finds
information, map data
for the map.
So we're going to jump
over to the NOAA
National Hurricane Center.
So NHC, they provide--
they're the authoritative
source of tropical storm
information for the US.
We're looking at the
website now.
You can see that there's one
tropical storm, Nadine.
For us, for the map geeks of the
world, we're looking for
kind of a data link.
So we're looking where we
can actually find data.
And they have a--
I believe it's GIS data sets, so
you click on that, and they
provide a slew of different data
that you're able to use
and play with.
So in our case, KML is
a format that we
really, really like.
It's an open standard.
It's owned by the community.
It's supported by a number of
Google products as well as
third-party applications.
It's based on XML.
So you can see here, there's
just a version of KML.
It's just XML, like I said.
It includes all of the styling
information, and importantly,
it plays really nicely
with Google Maps.
So what we do, we see that a
provider has a KML link.
It's one of the formats that
we support on Crisis Map.
We copy that link.
Crisis Map points at
third-party layers.
We do no data hosting.
And what we do, then, is to kind
of validate that the data
looks good.
We just paste that URL directly
into Google Maps, and
Google Maps will do the
rendering for us.
It'll show you what the KML
looks like via Maps.
If you pull it in via the Maps
API with KML layer, this is
exactly what you'll see.
So in this case, the
data looks good.
We see that, thankfully,
it's not on
course to make landfall.
And it's a relatively
weak storm.
So that's good.
So this is something that we
would add to a Crisis Map if
we were doing a Nadine
Crisis Map.
So Ping here has added
it to the map.
And you can see this is what,
indeed, it looks like.
So we have the link there.
The other thing that we do--
for people that--
we provide this for people that
want to look at the data
on a Crisis Map.
But for people that want to
actually bring it into their
own application or create their
own mashup, we provide
links to the source
data as well.
So you can see there that we
have the download KML link,
and this also works with
GEOSS layers as well.
These ones, it's really easy to
kind of mash up, so we do
try to provide--
improve the discoverability
of the raw data for that.
PAUL SAXMAN: So, quick
question about that.
If a developer wanted to do
their own mashup with a Crisis
Map and that type of
information, would you
recommend they actually embed
your map in their website, or
actually just pull the data out
and kind of build their
own map around it?
PETE GIENCKE: Yeah, so you
have many options.
So one of the things that we
provide, we have share
functionality.
So if you want to just take the
layers that we have and
provide your own kind of view
of that, we do spatial
bookmarking, we affectionately
call it.
So your view port and all the
layers that you have enabled,
once you click share, those
are saved in the URL.
So you can pass that around
with Google+, Twitter, or
Facebook, or you could
actually--
we provide the iframe
code, too.
So if you want to actually
just embed that in your
website, you can do that.
If you want to do your own
mashup, we definitely
encourage that.
We're developers.
We love to see different
people's takes on web mapping.
So we have KML and GEOSS links
there, so we encourage people
to do that as well
if they want to
customize what we have.
Because we're using open
standards, it means that you
can use open layers if
you want to do that.
Or we prefer Google Maps, but
there's other options as well.
And the one thing that I should
re-mention is that we
are looking to open source
this, too, so if there's
things that maybe you want to
customize this in some way,
just stay tuned and we should
be able to give you some new
hotness to play around with.
PAUL SAXMAN: Awesome.
PETE GIENCKE: OK, so I mentioned
KML is one of the
layers that we talked about.
Another life of a layer
is a Google Map tile.
So Google Map tiles
basically--
a Google Map tile is like when
you first load Google Maps,
and you see the road data
or the satellite,
those are all map tiles.
Google Maps allows you to
override the default map tiles
with your custom map tiles.
And that's a format that we
support with Crisis Maps.
So what we're looking
at now is the--
so NOAA flew a bunch of imagery
right after Hurricane
Isaac hit New Orleans.
They're making those data
available via their own
website, which is great, to have
some cool functionality.
You can download the raw data.
You can toggle the
transparency.
With Crisis Map, we think
there's a lot of value in kind
of mashing this up with other
different data sets.
So one of the things
that we did here--
because they're producing map
tiles, we're just able to
point at their data using
the map tile format.
So I think we have an
example of that.
So that's what a map
tile looks like.
It's basically the URL, and
Google Maps replaces the X, Y,
and Z with the location on the
map that those tiles reside.
And so we have an
example of that.
This is just the Mercator
scheme.
And then you can see that
they're organized into 16
tiles, and those increase as
you zoom into the math.
So map tiles are-- these
work really well.
Map tiles work great for
imagery, whereas, let's say
you have maybe a 2-gigabyte
image, you can break that into
bite-size pieces, into smaller
JPEGs and PNGs.
Also, for vector data, if you
have a very large data set and
you don't want to render that
as vector, you can turn that
into a raster and then
slice and dice that.
And there's many good tools
for doing that, many open
source tools.
I believe maptiler.org is one
that you can check out if you
want to create your
own map tiles.
PAUL SAXMAN: So tiling's kind
of an art and a science.
What tools do you guys
use specifically?
Is it something that external
developers--
PETE GIENCKE: So we love open
source tools, so maptiler.org,
I believe, is one of them.
There is an open source tool
that lots and lots of people
in the GIS world use.
It's called GDAL, G-D-A-L, and
there's something called
GDAL2tiles.
So that's part of the
GDAL package.
So people can just download
that, and then they can create
their own tiles that work
with Google Maps.
So it is kind of an art, but
there's high returns in terms
of being able to visualize
really complex data sets on a
web map once you're
able to do that.
So because the value of a map
really has a lot to do with
the underlying data and that
knowing that good data comes
in many different formats, we
try to support as many of
these kind of geo formats
as we can.
Maps API provides a lot of
these for free, like I
mentioned, so Fusion Tables,
KML, KMZ, GEOSS.
One of the things that we're
looking at is supporting
additional formats for the map,
especially some of the
more traditional GIS layers and
data sets, including PDF.
And we're looking at doing that
building on top of Google
App Engine.
So App Engine scales
extremely well.
We can serve lots and lots of
traffic and sleep well at
night knowing that we don't
have to manually tweak the
application just to make
sure it stays up.
This is an example here
where we're serving--
we have the imagery
coming to us.
We also have the PDF, if you
wanna maybe zoom into that.
Where is it?
KA-PING YEE: This one?
PETE GIENCKE: Yeah.
So this is the case here.
So we have the Mississippi
evacuation route.
We're playing about with
converting PDF into map tiles.
[AUDIO LOST]
the ability to kind of toggle
the transparency of that.
And this is especially
relevant where
you're dealing with--
for map tiles, where
you're dealing with
before and after imagery.
So you can turn on the
satellite and do the
comparison.
So we mentioned that this
application is really about
improving the discoverability
and accessibility of
crisis-related geo
data on the web.
And a lot of this has to do not
just with the data, but
with the presentation and
supporting many different
browsers and devices.
We've made a conscious decision
to really provide
only one version
of Crisis Map.
So there's not a separate
desktop and mobile version of
Crisis Map.
And that means that we're really
focusing on improving
the scalability of the map.
So what Ping has here, and we'll
show you, that the UI
elements on the map dynamically
resize themselves
based on the available
real estate.
So as we get closer and closer,
you'll see that the
search bar there kind
of disappeared.
As we get even closer, as the
screen real estate becomes
less and less, you'll see here
that the Layers panel is
actually like tucked
into button form.
So this would be kind of
representative of a tablet or
of a phone that has a
higher resolution.
And the beauty of this is that
we're able to make the same
kind of map data available on
a desktop as we are on a
mobile device.
One of the interesting data
points that we have, for
Hurricane Isaac, we saw over 20%
of access of Crisis Map on
these mobile devices,
not desktops.
And really, this reflects the
larger kind of macrotrend of
people moving away
from the desktop
onto tablets and phones.
But for crisis response
especially, where people are
being evacuated, they don't
necessarily take their desktop
or laptop with them.
They're looking for information
away from their homes.
So for us, it was a really
no-brainer decision to make
sure that mobile support was
a core functionality of the
product here.
PAUL SAXMAN: Did you guys see
any kind of trade-offs using
the Maps JS API versus, let's
say, the native Android
MapView first for building
the mobile application?
Or did you guys look at the
MapView, Android MapView
itself for--
KA-PING YEE: As Pete was
mentioning, we made the
conscious decision to build
this one app so that as we
added features to it, as we
continue to developing it, all
the features that we developed
would be available both on
desktop and mobile
at the same time.
So it's actually just
the same app.
And when it opens in mobile,
it's opening in a browser.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
So performance-wise,
though, everything
seems to work fairly--
KA-PING YEE: Yeah.
The V3 of the Maps API did
a lot of performance
enhancements specifically to
make it work well on mobile
and tablets.
And that's really
paid off for us.
PETE GIENCKE: OK, so I mentioned
the mobile support.
A big part of that is the
functionality, but another
part is the performance of
the application itself.
So if you're serving your
application out to phones that
don't have the same kind of I7
processor as your desktop
does, it means that you have to
pay a lot of attention to
performance and making sure
that the application just
performs really well.
So, for us, we used the Closure
JavaScript framework
to organize the code, but it
also allows us to optimize and
kind of shrink the code so it
downloads fast and runs fast.
An interesting kind of step
that we have is that our
JavaScript code is about 1.8
megabytes in size so all of
the code that we have
uncompressed.
And that's clearly too big to
send to a mobile device.
Using the Closure Compiler, we
were able to get that down by
over a factor of 10
to 160 kilobytes.
So that's a much smaller.
And then, we're using--
Closure provides the GDAL
module, which is basically a
dynamic loading mechanism, which
allows us to load only
what we need first.
And that takes the initial
JavaScript download size down
to about 45 kilobytes.
So for a mobile device, like
just imagine sending that 1.8
chunk of JavaScript versus
sending the 45 kilobytes just
to get the application loading
and getting the
data into the app.
Another thing that we should
mention is that we release
every two weeks.
And we want to make
that even--
improve the velocity
even more so we
release in shorter intervals.
And for that, we really need
automated tasks, and that
really also speaks to the
cross browser and mobile
support, like making sure we
don't have breakages and that
we're supporting the slew of
ways of accessing Crisis Map.
So we run our tests using
Google JS Test.
It's an open source project.
It runs in pure V8, which means
that the tests run fast.
And that's in italics--
fast.
There's no DOM included
with JS Test.
So we have to write
fakes for the DOM
documents and elements.
But the trade-off means that
we have 330 unit tasks that
run in under 5 seconds.
So we're testing.
And we do this continuously.
We're testing all parts of the
application on a unit testing
level, and it's just done
really quickly.
So we have tests that
run that fast.
We can run them as part of
the checking-in code.
So before I am able to check in
any code or Ping or anyone
else on the project, we
actually have to run
the suite of tests.
So that takes less than
5 seconds, so
it's not too painful.
But it just means that we're
not introducing any
regressions under the code base
when we're iterating so
quickly on the development
side.
PAUL SAXMAN: Wait, what do you
guys-- do you know what your
code coverage looks like?
How much of your code is
actually being tested?
KA-PING YEE: I don't have a
percentage number for that off
the top of my head, but we've
covered almost everything.
It's actually pretty good.
PETE GIENCKE: When you have 1.8
megabytes of JavaScript
code, there's a lot that
has to get tested.
KA-PING YEE: Can I do the
crazy keystroke demo?
PETE GIENCKE: Yes, definitely.
KA-PING YEE: So the really cool
thing is that, I mean,
even though all the tests run
in 5 seconds, running a test
for just a single file takes
like half a second or a
quarter of a second, which is so
fast that you can actually
run the tests while
you're editing.
So over on the right, I've got a
window that's running a test
continuously.
You can see it's actually
updating the test several
times per second.
PETE GIENCKE: And green
means good.
KA-PING YEE: Yeah,
and green's good.
And on the left, I've
got the same--
I've got the file that's
under test open.
And I can, as I'm typing into to
this file, I make a change,
and I can immediately see if
the tests are failing or
succeeding.
So I don't even have to go
through the process of opening
the file, editing it, saving
it, running the tests, and
then opening the file again
and changing it.
As I type, every keystroke I
type, I can immediately see
the results.
I've just broken that
missing character--
PAUL SAXMAN: Going to
check that one in?
PETE GIENCKE: Uh-huh.
KA-PING YEE: And it's fixed.
So that makes me feel a lot more
confident as I'm working
about making sure that
all the tests pass.
PETE GIENCKE: So, JS Test
for the web, basically.
KA-PING YEE: Yeah, yeah.
Check it out.
It's really amazingly fast.
PETE GIENCKE: OK.
So we just wanted to provide a
few highlights of Crisis Map.
It's good to talk about kind of
what's next, what we have
coming next.
So, better format support, I
mentioned that, especially for
more traditional GIS formats.
Our ability to be able to handle
additional content on
the web means that we're just
able to provide the best and
most complete picture of things
on the ground and
especially from the preparedness
standpoint, just
getting all of the data that
people need to make the
decisions on the ground, and
just make that available to
them without any kind
of special software.
Trust signals and visual cues
to improve understanding of
the data so, things like
metadata coming
from the GIS world.
Metadata is a four-letter
word, but it really is
important, like telling
people when the
data were last updated.
So like the shelters for
instance, people want to know
that there's a certain
number of beds there.
They want to know that the
evacuation routes are still
valid, so providing that kind of
information to allow people
to really trust the data is
something that we want to do.
More support for user-generated
content.
On the crisis response space,
we're seeing efforts like
Ushahidi really pay off in terms
of allowing affected
people-- provide information
that's relevant to responders
and the rest of the community.
And we really want to do a
better job of surfacing that
data to provide that, like I
said, more complete picture of
things on the ground.
And we're doing some
of that now.
We have YouTube videos that
people are providing.
We have webcams, but there's a
lot more that we can do there.
And then open sourcing is
another thing that I
mentioned as well.
So I would say check out
google.org Crisis Map.
We'd love to hear any feedback
that you have.
And before handing it back to
Paul, I should also say that
we're hiring.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, awesome.
Yeah, it sounds like you guys
have the technologies down.
Sounds like a pretty fun job.
So--
PETE GIENCKE: We sleep
all the nights.
PAUL SAXMAN: So do you guys get
to take vacations around
hurricane seasons or is that--
that's your only--
PETE GIENCKE: The nice thing
is that we have a worldwide
team, so we have folks
in Sydney.
We have folks in Japan.
We have a New York office.
And we have a Mountain View
contingent as well so that we
are able to take vacations.
Knowing that events happen all
over the world, there's going
to be someone that can
pick up, to help out
when something happens.
PAUL SAXMAN: So where do people
go if they want to look
at the job?
Do you guys have it posted
on the job site?
PETE GIENCKE: It should be.
Check out google.org, sorry,
google.com/jobs and search for
Crisis Response.
Otherwise, just hit me up on
Google+ and I'd be happy to
refer you to an open position or
just give you the details.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
I'm going to take a quick peek
and see what kind of
questions we've got.
Oops, got to reload the page.
PETE GIENCKE: And I'll just
watch the YouTube video here
of the caterpillar.
PAUL SAXMAN: I can watch
myself right now live.
OK.
Let's see.
Recording.
I don't see anything
on here right now.
There's a couple questions
that I had just
listening to you guys.
So you did mention
open sourcing.
So what are we looking at?
I mean, are you--
sometime this year, maybe
early next year?
PETE GIENCKE: So I would
say stay tuned.
We're working on it right now.
For a sneak peek, a previous
version of Crisis Map, it was
done by the Sydney team.
It's called Map Visage,
code.google.com/mapvisage or
mapvisage.appspot.com.
Basically, that's the
template for how
we're going to do this.
So to live at code.google.com,
it'll be an App Engine
instance, and it's basically
everything you need to stand
on your own, stand up
your own Crisis Map.
So stay tuned, and we should
be able to provide an
announcement of that
when it happens.
So hopefully sooner
rather than later.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
I think that's everything.
So, again, this is Pete Giencke
and Ka-Ping Yee.
You can find Pete on Google+
if you wanna ask any
questions, and feel free to
ask any questions on our
YouTube channel.
And we can try to answer
them there.
Coming up next week, I think
we're back down in Sydney,
potentially talking with
one of the new PMs
on the Places API.
And two weeks out, I
think we might have
GEO for Good coming.
So definitely stay tuned.
We'll have everything posted
on the Google+ channel.
Thanks for watching, and see
you guys in the next week.
KA-PING YEE: Thanks, Paul.
[MUSIC PLAYING]